chris how does it feel not just to win
but but to be performing live again in
front of your peers
well it's a fantastic feeling that's uh
a lot of what we do this for is because
we like that moment in the room where
everybody can kind of be together and
that's uh something that you can't
replicate over a
zoom call like we're doing right now so
thank you
all right we'll do our next question in
person
right here on your right hi topher roger
with people i wonder if you have took
away three trophies tonight you have
eight total how does this feel does it
feel any different now does it feel old
at all at this point
definitely doesn't feel old um
you know anytime that you are even
nominated for award or
uh someone thinks enough of you to
invite you to these
kinds of shows
uh particularly grammys
it's uh
you know it's a very surreal moment and
uh we had a very surreal moment
all day today and so it was it was a
very and to get to play a song you know
with that i wrote with
the guys in the band on the show
want to grab me for it earlier in the
uh
in the evening and uh it you know what a
special night for for me
for me it's special and it's special
getting to do with those guys we do it
every night
really really special
all right our next question is going to
be on the screen virtual
ethan with rolling stone on the center
screen
hey chris can you hear me hi ethan how
are you
i'm all right yeah congratulations and
happy birthday to your daughters by the
way that's my sons but i've got two sons
oh excuse me your sons yeah
happy birthday thank you well uh
congratulations like everyone else said
but i wanted to ask you you alluded this
a bit already but why writing cold with
your band members was so important to
you you write with so many different
people but this was with people that you
tour with
well we wrote it on the road we were
backstage jamming
uh or they the guys were backstage
jamming what became the groove for that
song and i came in and i was like hey
you guys keep playing that because we're
just warming up we have a little warm-up
kit and
rigged backstage every night
and that song was very very organically
came out of just a jam backstage
and so
we hope those things pop out sometimes
but they're not
uh you know we didn't sit down and and
map it out that way that just
it just came to be and that and that
those are the best moments sometimes uh
for songs
all right i think we're gonna bring the
band up on stage for some additional
questions
[Applause]
all right here you hold that one
first question is going to be on our
right over here
premier networks uh
you brought the band up but you also had
a crew member who was uh kind of
involved in this doing introductions uh
how did that come about
i don't really know the answer to that
question
but it was uh really cool uh to get you
know to have katie introduce us because
katie does so much for us on the road
and um
yeah i don't know how it came about i
think i think it might have been
somebody at the grammys idea to have
members of the crew introducing people
so i thought it was a great uh you know
little tie-in to what we all do
all right next question is going to be
virtual on our screen straight ahead
this is andrea with abc
hi chris and the band congratulations
all you guys uh chris can you talk about
what it's been like returning to the
road after being sidelined for so long
due to the pandemic i know you came back
and you came back hard you throw
hard is it more special now
well you certainly uh gained an
appreciation for uh what we had lost and
uh which was
um
getting to interact with people every
night and hear people sing you know
songs back to you but see smiles on
their faces and people having a good
time and
you know
the communion that that brings you know
is just kind of
it's a wonderful thing
and
we certainly missed it it was 504 days i
think we we didn't play a show so we
were certainly counting the days and the
hours until we got to do it again
all right last question is going to be
on the left-hand side
hi chris and the band uh congratulations
dana cortez cbs
news you've collaborated with some of
the biggest artists in the world written
uh you jam you're featured on carlos
santana's album you're the only country
artist on there is there anyone you have
not worked with
that you would like to
that i would like to that you would like
to
oh there are lots and lots of people but
um you know
i do those things when they come up and
when when the time is right and they
have all happen organically
i
i don't want to have a specific answer
for you probably but um
because i'm blanking right now but
um there's so many great artists and and
um i like harry styles a lot harry
styles
makes some really great music he's a
great singer
great songwriter yeah
all right thank you so much to chris and
the band congratulations again